La diagonalizzazione quantistica di Krylov, o KQD in breve, si riferisce alla risoluzione di un problema agli autovalori di una matrice
proiettando la matrice in un sottospazio preparato su un computer quantistico, in conformità con il metodo di Krylov, un
potente approccio dall'algebra lineare classica. In questo video esploreremo a cosa serve il metodo di Krylov
e come e quando implementarlo sui computer quantistici.
Cos'è quindi il metodo di Krylov? Supponi di avere una matrice H relativa a un problema scientifico o aziendale con n righe e n
colonne. Siamo interessati all'autovalore più basso e0 e al corrispondente autovettore ψ0. Definiamo un
vettore iniziale v, che potrebbe essere motivato dalla struttura di H oppure essere del tutto casuale. Il sottospazio di Krylov
di ordine r, che scriviamo Kr, viene generato applicando H a questo
vettore iniziale r meno uno volte, aggiungendo il risultato di ogni successiva applicazione di H
all'insieme dei vettori di spanning, ovvero Kr è lo spazio generato dai vettori v,
Hv, H al quadrato e così via. Questi vettori in generale non saranno ortogonali.
Classicamente, si esegue spesso un processo di ortogonalizzazione molto simile alla procedura di Gram-Schmidt. Si parte
normalizzando il vettore iniziale V e si chiama il risultato V0. Poi per il vettore successivo HV, si sottrae la sua
proiezione su V0 per rendere i due vettori ortogonali. Si normalizza quindi il risultato. Si continua così,
applicando di nuovo H e rendendo il risultato ortogonale a tutti i vettori aggiunti in precedenza, fino a costruire R
vettori ortonormali necessari a generare il sottospazio di Krylov di dimensione R.
Una volta ottenuto questo sottospazio, si proietta la matrice su di esso e si diagonalizza la matrice proiettata più piccola. Ci sono
sottigliezze ed estensioni, ma questo è il metodo di Krylov nella sua forma più semplice.
Per capire meglio come funziona, guardiamo un esempio banale. Se H è questa matrice e V è scelto come questo
vettore, inizieremmo normalizzando V. Per generare il secondo vettore nel sottospazio di Krylov, applichiamo
H una volta al nostro vettore iniziale e poi rendiamo quel risultato ortogonale a V0.
Un po' di algebra fornisce questo per V1.
Non è utile per matrici così piccole e in genere non ci si fermerebbe a una dimensione di Krylov pari a due. Ma se
dovessimo proiettare H sul nostro nuovo spazio di Krylov K2, lo faremmo usando una matrice V
che ha un vettore di Krylov per ogni colonna e il suo trasposto coniugato, che ha i vettori di Krylov per le righe. Otterremmo quindi
questa matrice.
Questa matrice ha tecnicamente dimensione inferiore rispetto all'originale. Ovviamente questa riduzione non è utile a questa
scala. Questo metodo è pensato per ridurre matrici con molte migliaia o addirittura milioni di righe e colonne
a poche unità. Perché quindi i metodi di Krylov sono utili? Si scopre che questa semplice prescrizione
dell'azione dell'operatore è spesso il modo più efficiente per approssimarsi allo stato di valore più basso, o stato fondamentale, di un operatore
matriciale. Rendiamo questo concetto un po' più esplicito, anche se lasciamo la dimostrazione completa al testo di accompagnamento. Vogliamo
risolvere un problema della forma H applicato al vettore x che dà una costante moltiplicata per il vettore x. Partiamo con un'
ipotesi per il nostro autovettore x0. Questa è solo una soluzione approssimata. Ha un errore che chiamiamo e0. Ora vogliamo
fare un aggiornamento di questa ipotesi, che chiameremo x1, sperando che migliori la nostra approssimazione. Possiamo esprimerlo come
l'originale x0 più una correzione p0 ancora da determinare. Possiamo
ripetere questo processo in modo iterativo, aggiungendo sempre più vettori di correzione pi.
Ovviamente vogliamo ridurre l'errore, ma non ci interessa solo lo stato. Ci interessa anche l'
azione di H su quello stato. Quindi la quantità che vogliamo davvero minimizzare è la norma H di questo errore, ovvero la norma dell'
azione di H su questo errore.
Ora possiamo vedere che si tratta di un'espressione che coinvolge p0 e possiamo chiederci quali scelte di p minimizzano
questa norma H dell'errore in modo più efficiente. Da quale spazio dovremmo selezionare la correzione? In certe
condizioni, come quando H è simmetrica e definita positiva, scegliere le prime r correzioni all'interno di Kr risulta
essere ottimale. In termini più semplici, abbiamo bisogno di un modo per preparare un buon sottospazio su cui
proiettare il nostro Hamiltoniano. E in molti casi, il sottospazio di Krylov è lo spazio generato dai vettori delle correzioni più
efficienti alla nostra ipotesi iniziale.
Per una dimostrazione rigorosa, consulta il testo che accompagna questo video.
Tutto ciò che abbiamo descritto finora può essere fatto in modo classico. Come e quando useremmo quindi un computer quantistico?
Per matrici molto grandi, il metodo di Krylov può richiedere lunghi tempi di calcolo e grandi quantità di memoria. Il tempo
richiesto per l'operazione matriciale di H su V scala come N al quadrato nel caso peggiore.
E questo viene fatto per ogni vettore che vogliamo nel nostro sottospazio. La dimensione del sottospazio R di solito non è una frazione significativa
di N e spesso scala come il logaritmo di N. Quindi generare tutti i vettori scala
come O(N² log N).
Sebbene ci siano altri passaggi come l'ortogonalizzazione, questa è la scala dominante da tenere a mente.
Il calcolo quantistico ci permette di cambiare quali attributi del problema determinano la scala del tempo e delle risorse
necessari. Invece della dipendenza dalla dimensione della matrice n in tutto, vedremo cose come il numero di shots e
il numero di termini di Pauli non commutanti che compongono un Hamiltoniano.
Esploriamo come funziona.
Ricorda che l'operatore che fa evolvere temporalmente uno stato quantistico è l'esponenziale di iH diviso per h-barra. Ed è
molto comune, specialmente nel calcolo quantistico, omettere h-barra dalla notazione.
Un modo per comprendere e persino realizzare tale funzione esponenziale di un operatore è guardare la sua serie di Fourier
in espansione. Nota che questa operazione applicata a un certo vettore iniziale V produce una somma di termini
con potenze crescenti di H applicate allo stato iniziale. Sembra che possiamo costruire il nostro sottospazio di Krylov semplicemente facendo evolvere nel tempo
il nostro stato iniziale. Ed è quasi vero. Il caveat sta nel
realizzare l'evoluzione temporale su un vero computer quantistico. Molti dei termini nell'Hamiltoniano non commutano tra loro.
Quindi, mentre alcuni operatori esponenziali semplici come e alla meno iZ corrispondono a circuit
semplici, gli Hamiltoniani generali no, e poiché contengono termini non commutanti
non possiamo semplicemente decomporre l'esponenziale in un prodotto di esponenziali semplici come si fa con i numeri. Quindi
non è banale, ma si tratta di un processo ben studiato nel calcolo quantistico. Realizziamo l'evoluzione temporale
sui computer quantistici usando un processo chiamato trotterizzazione, che è di per sé un argomento ricco. Ma ad alto livello,
dividendo l'evoluzione temporale in piccoli passi, diciamo M passi, limitiamo gli effetti della non-commutatività dei
termini. Chiamiamo il sottospazio di Krylov di ordine r che abbiamo generato nel contesto classico usando le potenze di H
direttamente il sottospazio di Krylov di potenza KPr.
Ora generiamo uno spazio simile usando l'operatore di evoluzione temporale unitario U dato dall'esponenziale di iHt.
Lo chiameremo sottospazio di Krylov unitario KUr.
Il sottospazio di Krylov di potenza KPr che utilizziamo classicamente non può essere generato direttamente su un computer quantistico poiché H non è
un operatore unitario. L'uso del sottospazio di Krylov unitario può essere dimostrato fornire garanzie di convergenza simili
a quelle del sottospazio di Krylov di potenza.
In particolare, l'errore sullo stato fondamentale converge in modo efficiente purché lo stato iniziale V abbia sovrapposizione con il
vero stato fondamentale che non si annulli esponenzialmente e purché vi sia un gap sufficiente tra gli auto-
stati. Qui le potenze di U diventano diversi passi temporali. La k-esima potenza di U corrisponde ad avanzare
di un tempo k * dt.
Possiamo etichettare l'elemento del sottospazio evoluto temporalmente per un tempo totale kdt come s sub k. Possiamo proiettare il nostro
Hamiltoniano H sul sottospazio di Krylov unitario KUr. In altre parole,
calcoliamo ogni elemento di matrice di H nella base KUr. Chiameremo questa
matrice proiettata H tilde. Gli elementi di matrice di H tilde sono dati da questi valori di aspettazione, che possono essere
stimati usando il computer quantistico.
Tieni presente che H può essere scritto come una somma di operatori di Pauli su diversi qubit e che non tutti gli operatori di Pauli
possono essere misurati simultaneamente. Possiamo raggruppare i termini di Pauli in gruppi di termini commutanti e misurare tutti
quelli insieme. Ma potremmo aver bisogno di molti gruppi per coprire tutti i termini. Quindi il numero di gruppi commutanti distinti in cui
i termini possono essere partizionati, ngcp, diventa importante. Se usiamo un sottospazio di Krylov unitario di dimensione r, la
matrice risultante avrà dimensioni r × r. Se r è molto minore di n, abbiamo
fatto progressi utili, e tipicamente r è molto minore di 100, il che significa che possiamo diagonalizzare facilmente su un computer classico.
Ma ricorda che s_n e s_m in generale non saranno ortogonali. A volte è
possibile diagonalizzare una matrice in una base non ortogonale. Ma ci sono ragioni numeriche e fisiche
per passare prima a una base ortogonale. Quindi risolviamo un problema agli autovalori generalizzato usando la matrice di Gram S.
L'elemento mn della matrice di Gram è dato dal prodotto interno di s_m con s_n.
Sia gli elementi di H tilde che quelli di S vengono calcolati usando un test di Hadamard.
Il problema agli autovalori generalizzato diventa quindi questo.
Come notato sopra, la dimensione del sottospazio di Krylov unitario R è esponenzialmente più piccola della dimensione della matrice iniziale
N. Quindi questo problema agli autovalori è semplice da risolvere classicamente.
Per ricapitolare, partiamo da uno stato di riferimento, poi lo facciamo evolvere per diversi periodi di tempo per generare il sottospazio di Krylov unitario.
Proiettiamo il nostro Hamiltoniano su quel sottospazio e stimiamo anche le sovrapposizioni dei
vettori del sottospazio. Infine, risolviamo il problema agli autovalori generalizzato di dimensione inferiore classicamente. Confrontiamo cosa
determina i costi computazionali nell'uso della tecnica di Krylov in modo classico e quantistico. Abbiamo già abbozzato questo
per la versione classica e non ci sono analogie perfette tra gli approcci classico e quantistico per tutti i passaggi. Ma questa tabella raccoglie alcune
scale di diversi passaggi per considerazione. Ricorda che gli Hamiltoniani hanno generalmente termini che non possono essere misurati simultaneamente perché non
commutano. Raggruppiamo i termini nell'Hamiltoniano in gruppi di operatori di Pauli commutanti che possono essere tutti misurati simultaneamente e potremmo aver bisogno di molti
gruppi per tenere conto di tutti i termini che non commutano. Per costruire H tilde su un computer quantistico sono necessarie
misurazioni separate per ogni gruppo di stringhe di Pauli commutanti nell'Hamiltoniano. E ognuna richiede molti shots. Dobbiamo farlo per R
al quadrato diversi elementi di matrice corrispondenti a R² combinazioni di diversi fattori di evoluzione temporale. A volte
ci sono modi per ridurre questo. Ma in questa trattazione approssimativa, il tempo richiesto scala approssimativamente come
il numero di shots moltiplicato per il numero di gruppi di termini di Pauli commutanti × r².
Gli elementi di S devono essere stimati, il che scala come il numero di shots
al cubo. Vediamo che la diagonalizzazione quantistica di Krylov potrebbe essere utile nei casi in cui il numero di gruppi di Pauli commutanti
nell'Hamiltoniano è relativamente piccolo.
Questa dipendenza dalla scala suggerisce alcune applicazioni in cui il metodo di Krylov può essere utile e altre in cui probabilmente
non lo sarà. Alcuni Hamiltoniani hanno alta complessità quando mappati ai qubit, coinvolgendo molte stringhe di Pauli non commutanti
che non possono essere facilmente partizionate in pochi gruppi commutanti.
Questo è spesso vero per i problemi di chimica quantistica. Per esempio, questa complessità presenta due sfide principali per i
computer quantistici di breve termine. Primo, la stima di ogni elemento di H tilde diventa computazionalmente costosa a causa dell'
elevato numero di termini. Secondo, i circuit di Trotter richiesti diventano proibitivamente profondi. Entrambi questi punti
saranno meno problematici quando i computer quantistici raggiungeranno la tolleranza agli errori, ma devono essere considerati a breve termine. Anche i sistemi con mappature più semplici
rispetto a quelli della chimica quantistica possono subire gli stessi impedimenti se gli Hamiltoniani hanno troppi termini non commutanti.
Il metodo di Krylov è più utile quando l'Hamiltoniano può essere partizionato in relativamente pochi gruppi di Pauli commutanti
e quando H è facile da implementare nei circuit di Trotter. Entrambe queste condizioni sono soddisfatte, per
esempio, per molti modelli reticolari di interesse in fisica. KQD è particolarmente utile quando si sa molto poco sullo
stato fondamentale. Questo deriva dalle sue intrinseche garanzie di convergenza e dalla sua applicabilità in scenari in cui
i metodi alternativi sono inattuabili per insufficiente conoscenza dello stato fondamentale.
Sebbene KQD sia uno strumento potente, gli aspetti più dispendiosi in termini di tempo del protocollo, in particolare la stima di ogni
elemento dell'Hamiltoniano proiettato e la sovrapposizione degli stati di Krylov, rappresentano opportunità di miglioramento. Un
approccio alternativo consiste nell'approssimare lo stato di Krylov usando circuit di Trotter, poi campionare lo
stato approssimato per ottenere una proiezione sulla base computazionale e poi proiettare H sul sottospazio
generato da questi stati della base computazionale.
Nei casi in cui è applicabile, questa metodologia nota come diagonalizzazione quantistica di Krylov basata sul campionamento, SKQD,
offre potenzialmente riduzioni significative nei requisiti di tempo e risorse rispetto al KQD tradizionale.
L'integrazione delle tecniche di sottospazio di Krylov con i metodi di campionamento in SKQD rappresenta un'entusiasmante frontiera negli
algoritmi quantistici.